smoke is still pouring from burning
buildings in maryenka a suburb of
Donetsk rebels say that the ukrainian
army shelled the area killing at least
30 civilians I have no words to express
my outrage fear and confusion look here
this is the face of our president
poroshenko he's not our president this
is his true face the attack came after
Kia vowed to retaliate for the killing
of 23 Ukrainian soldiers on Friday the
Army says it's pushing back the rebels
in order to retake Donetsk and Luhansk
computers in the past 24 hours the
Ukrainian Air Force delivered five
targeted but powerful air strikes on
terrorist strongholds their mortar and
firing positions and rebel camps in the
Luhansk and Donetsk regions with you in
the capital the government publicly
displayed artillery and tanks they say
were captured from the rebels they say
the weaponry proves that the separatists
are being supported by Russia meanwhile
some Donetsk inhabitants have been
returning to their shelled homes to
salvage personal items many are fleeing
the area to avoid further fighting